[Music]
William Golding was losing his faith in
humanity serving aboard a British
destroyer in World War two the
philosophy teacher turned Royal Navy
lieutenant was constantly confronted by
the atrocities of his fellow man and
when he returned to England to find Cold
War superpowers threatening one another
with nuclear annihilation he was forced
to interrogate the very roots of human
nature these musings on the
inevitability of violence would inspire
his first and most famous novel Lord of
the Flies after being rejected by 21
publishers the novel was finally
published in 1954 it takes its title
from Beelzebub a demon associated with
Pride and war two themes very much at
the heart of Goulding's book the novel
was a bleak satire of a classic Island
adventure story a popular genre where
young boys get shipwrecked in exotic
locations the protagonists in these
stories are able to master nature while
evading the dangers posed by their new
environments the genre also endorsed the
problematic colonialists narrative found
in many British works at the time in
which the boys teach the island's native
inhabitants their allegedly superior
British values Goulding's satire even
goes so far as to explicitly use the
setting and character names from RM
Ballantine's coral island one of the
most beloved Island adventure novels but
while Ballantine's book promised readers
pleasure profit and unbounded amusement
Goulding's had darker things in store
Lord of the Flies opens with the boys
already on the island but snippets of
conversation hint at their terrifying
journey their plane had been shot down
in the midst of an unspecified nuclear
war the boys ranging in age from 6 to 13
are strangers to each other all except
for a choir clad in black uniforms and
led by a boy named Jack just as in
Ballantine's coral island the boys new
home appears to be a paradise with fresh
water shelter and abundant food
but even from the novels opening pages a
McCobb darkness hangs over this
seemingly tranquil situation
the boys shadows are compared to black
bat light creatures while the choir
itself first appears as something dark
fumbling along the beach within hours of
their arrival the boys are already
trading terrifying rumors of a vicious
beastie lurking in the woods from these
ominous beginnings Goulding's narrative
reveals how quickly cooperation unravels
without the presence of an adult
Authority initially the survivors try to
establish some sense of order a boy
named Ralph blows into a conch shell to
assemble the group and delegate tasks
but as Jack dies for leadership with
Ralph the group splinters and the boys
submit to their darker urges the mob of
children soon forgets their plans for
rescue silences the few voices of reason
and blindly follows Jack to the edge of
the island and the edge of sanity the
novel's universal themes of morality
civility and society have made it a
literary classic satirizing both
conventions of its time and long-held
beliefs about humanity while Island
Adventure stories often support
colonialism Lord of the Flies turns this
trope on its head rather than cruelly
casting native populations as
stereotypical savages Golding transforms
his angelic British school boys into
savage caricatures and as the boys fight
their own battle on the island the far
more destructive war that brought them
there continues off the page even if the
boys were to be rescued from themselves
what kind of world would they be
returning to with so few references to
anchor the characters in a specific
place or period the novel feels truly
timeless an examination of human nature
at its most bare and though not all
readers may agree with Goulding's grim
view Lord of the Flies is unsettling
enough to challenge even the most
determined optimist can you preserve
your mind in a society where free will
self-expression
and curiosity are punishable offenses
continue exploring this classic
conundrum with our video on Fahrenheit
451
[Music]